[Music]
I want to be where the people are
I want to see you wanna see them dancing
walking around on those what do you call
them oh feet
flipping your fins
are required for jumping dancing
[Music]
wish I could be
Sebastian if you had just seen it up
there the ship rode on the wind and they
filled the sky with fire okay okay
listen to me the human world is a mess
life under the sea is better than
anything they got going on up there this
evening is always greener if somebody
else's league
is a big mistake just look at the world
around you right here on the ocean floor
such wonderful things surround you what
more is you're looking for another
sea
darling is better don't worry sweater
take it from me
up on the shore they work all day out in
the sun they slave away while we devoted
full time to floating
I see
[Music]
which
so here's the deal
I'll whip up a little potion to make you
human for three days got that three days
before the sun sets on the third day you
and princy must share a kiss and not
just any kiss because of true love
if you do you will remain human
ly
but a few jokes
you'll turn back into a mermaid
and you belong
[Music]
I admit that in the past I've been a
nasty they weren't kidding when they
called me well a witch but
find that nowadays I've Blended all my
ways true
yes
and I fortunately know a little magic
dance
[Music]
pathetic
unfortunately
wants to give the girl and do I help
them yes indeed
oh
no
ah get off me you fool oh hey didn't
expect to find you here and I really
didn't expect to find her here hey you
listen to me bird the king can never
hear this we are going to forget this
ever happened
are you listening to me yes sir you
won't tell him I won't tell him and I
will stay in one piece you got it got it
sorry what'd you say again I'm a dead
crab
s
[Music]
these songs
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
to the above World a man was drowning I
had to save him this obsession with
humans has to stop I want to know more
about them
[Music]
poor child I can help you you can't live
in that Wilderness you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
hahaha
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
[Music]
someday
he's a Healer you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
thank you
I really didn't expect to find her here
the king can never hear it is you got it
got it sorry what'd you say again I'm a
dead crab
wind casting I hope that the actor comes
in and claims the role someone who could
bring that Vision to life life under the
sea is better than anything they got
going on up there this is the coolest
thing I've ever been a part of there was
a lot of training to play the characters
do you want to try a stunt training boat
training voice training dog training Gym
training I just I feel so trained Rob
would often encourage me to like ad-lib
you know why don't you tell me something
nice hey Scuttle I like your hair I like
the center part because the side part
looks like it's receding a little bit I
love you Sebastian and I want to get
married to you and I want to do it in
Vegas and I want my family to be there
as Witnesses
Jacob is so amazing as flounder you know
you can't back down you gotta show them
who's in charge
to King of the Seas those are big shoes
to fail I got to be Javier or damn's
sister and it was just so incredible to
work with him but boy you feel those
lightning bolts come out this ends now
Melissa McCarthy as Ursula is a dream
yes and it was hard to not like her in
the film which is amazing
[Music]
I couldn't believe how beautiful it was
how connected it was it was so moving
[Music]
a beautiful day
I loved working with the cast that bond
is there it's truly a family
[Applause]
[Music]
quiet for jumping dancing I literally do
not understand how this is all happening
just give me chills thinking about it
the character of Ariel is a girl who
feels displaced she wants something more
and you feel that in every pour of La
the outpouring when we release that
teaser and just kid after kid
the world is so excited to see this role
I'm really excited for that moment to
finally happen
we were upset every day and there's
always a beautiful very soft Melody that
she's just humming along to I never said
anything I never wanted her to stop just
to feel Hallie be that little mermaid I
think we're gonna feel that for a long
time
I'm just so excited for people to see
The Little Mermaid Ariel has drive and
passion and gumption
Ali is one of the most memorable and
incredible experiences of this job so
talented she's amazing in my heart my
five-year-old little self she
I think she would just be blown away
[Music]
when I first saw the original Little
Mermaid my whole world changed
[Music]
like so many of us little girls we all
just wanted to be mermaids
I think the little mermaid is an iconic
powerful story it was important to
expand and make it a fuller experience
this little mermaid reflects what it
means to want something greater for
yourself
and that's a voice Halle Bailey when she
sang for us it was so emotional she set
the bar and no one ever surpassed it
I've been watching you for a long time
now too Melissa McCarthy as Ursula she's
extraordinary she's so dishy and
conniving we got a deal I mean I'll just
give you the premium package kit she's
hilarious and terrifying true
in
is The Little Mermaid was the first film
I ever scored it's especially emotional
coming back and with lin-manuel Miranda
who was so brilliant the songs we've
written expand what little mermaid is I
feel really proud to work on The Little
Mermaid because these characters live in
my heart
[Music]
know how but I know something's starting
right now
the world that Rob Marshall created
precious boundaries he's doing something
special
it's just a dream come true
[Music]
thank you